They don't have to believe it.
That's pure narcissism at work,
by the way,
you don't want to hijack hijacking event
like this and other people put time and
effort into and to use the civility of
the crowd and the civility of the
organizers as an excuse to blatantly
yellow.
You're ill informed opinions is no way
to conduct a civil dialogue.
It's absolutely appalling.
The people who do that should be
embarrassed.
Thank you.
Yes.
I would also say that as students and as
faculty members,
you shouldn't put up with it.
There is no way that you should allow
people who are doing this to hijack your
educational opportunities and to bend
and twist the functions and the
structures of the university.
It's not a good thing.
Not In any way at all.
I would say that was a very disgraceful
display fundamentally,
so let's stick with it.
Why?
Why do you think people are afraid of
free speech?
Well,
you know,
people develop an ideological view of
the world because they don't want to
think through things in real detail and
they're aided and embedded in that
endeavor by their pathological
professors who are feeding them.
What would I say?
Oversimplified an oversimplified radical
view of the world,
in my estimation,
is fundamentally based in,
in resentment.
Not that there's no reason for say,
a left wing view of the world and we can
get to that later.
It's easy virtue.
You know,
you can stand up in front of 900 people
with your art and your and your
screeching and you can.
You can declaim to the entire audience
your fundamental moral superiority.
You can tell everyone at once that
they're all beneath you and you're
standing for the right thing and
absolutely none of that is earned.
You know,
like,
what the hell?
What the hell was that?
There's,
it's come seriously man.
There's just,
it's just complete misbehavior.
It's embarrassing and the fact that the
people who do that don't have enough
sense to go hide their head in shame
just tells you how badly socialize they
are and how terribly educated they are.
And the thing is,
the thing that's so awful is that there
are professors and educators who promote
that and say,
well,
that's how you change the world.
It's like it is how you change the
world,
but it's certainly not how you make it
better.
You make it worse.
Clearly,
you know,
there is no comfort in that and there's
nothing about it.
Impressive.
It's no,
it's no better in some sense than a two
year old having a tantrum on the floor.
It shows,
as far as I'm concerned,
it approximately the same level of
psychosocial development.
So when the fact that this is happening
continually,
universities is,
it's,
it truly makes me embarrassed to be
associated with the university.
And now I say that with great
displeasure because,
you know,
I've been working for great universities
for a very long time and the university
is an absolutely remarkable institution.
You know,
it's survived for a thousand years and,
and to see it,
to see it brought down by by people
whose behavior would be out of place at
a four year old's birthday party is is
something something bizible to behold.